by definition nonprofits are not
designed to make a lot of money in most
cases they're designed to help and they
need donations to survive if the depth
of the pandemic strained services rising
inflation and costs they have strained
finances at even our largest non-profits
christian cousidus is here to look at
the struggles these organizations are
facing right now christian well john we
reached out to several local nonprofits
who tell us donations are down but they
say it's understandable they know
nevadans want to help but many are
struggling with inflation and even high
gas prices overall the demand is growing
but not the supply
yesterday alone we were over 150
families
that's an average of 4 000 families a
month a powerful aid according to deacon
tom roberts with catholic charities of
southern nevada who says their workers
and volunteers are working hard to meet
the community needs but that need he
says has been growing over the last
couple of months we are seeing an
increase in people coming people are
obviously concerned about driving here
because of the cost of fuel
they're concerned about can they make
food stretch longer as nevadans along
with so many americans continue to send
aid to families impacted by the war in
ukraine local organizations say they
have seen a slight decline in donations
but not all is lost we're really happy
that that and that we've seen that you
know corporations and even government
have tried to step up and fill some of
those gaps organizations like the nevada
partnership of homeless youth say they
are tackling homelessness early but they
can't do it alone community sport
overall is
strong however it has changed others say
donations are flowing steadily but the
need is dire because of the high cost of
food every cost is greater for that
matter for a household it narrows down
their ability to buy food
decisions have to be made and decisions
are you know sometimes made between rent
medicine and food and sometimes food
gives
well all the organizations that we spoke
to today say people can help in so many
different ways they can make a food or
item donation cash of course is always
great and you can do so through their
websites but also volunteering is highly
highly needed right now now if you would
like to help out check out our website
eightnewsnow.com for all those details
christian casa is live local now